two First Act to be on on the rise
that's crazy bro [ __ ] I'm gonna be I
appreciate y'all having me feeling good
I'm gonna be on GQ what's up GQ it's
little meech the Boss Of All Bosses and
you watching on the rocks
I've really been in surgery since I was
a baby growing up you can go through my
dad got locked up and I was around him
as a kid I got to see you know the drugs
back then I didn't really understand
what it was but as I got older and
started to talk to Emma you know he
always had me with changed and watches
that [ __ ] but he was just to tell me all
the watches and shoes about me as a baby
and all the [ __ ] I used to have he was
the first one going to Jacob for real
Jacob was one like Top Line like if not
one of the best Jewelers in the world
popsically going to Jacob in 2000s and
90s like been doing that so and ever
since I was going there myself you know
I always wanted to get my own [ __ ] you
know I had my first two BMF pieces I
went and bought but after that I went to
Elliott I mean earlier like this my
brother earlier did my new BMF piece my
old BMP pieces don't have no more to me
is the best drill in the world his
jewelry is priceless and Timeless like
it's just a different type of
craftsmanship that he does whether
Elliot charged me 200 000 just for this
Cuban this Cuban is like 1100 grams it's
chunky real big I already can't had his
own for longer than three four hours my
neck started the lock you say eliance
you know say his name his signature they
got the three big boogers on each side
so ain't no regular cue you know you
might find a regular cue on some 50 or
for a hundred maybe but
you know it's two 200 just for a kilo
what's the pending poster three just for
the pending
bigger than this you know you don't see
no silver or gold you see straight
Waters how does it feel to tell your
father in being man first of all it's I
can't even put in the words how I feel
so you know this is something that him
and 50 Cent talked about while I was a
teenager in high school still he told me
like I really don't know who's gonna
play me but I really want you to play me
50 Cent held his first casting call in
Atlanta my dad told me to fly out there
so I can meet him for the first time I
actually met 50. he was looking at me
just I seen him just looking at me he's
just like man I want you to play your
box can't be nobody else but you I'm
looking at you right now he like you
just him
he lie down for to put you up in acting
classes I need you to move to LA he paid
for it made sure I was good all I had to
do was show up I had two acting classes
a day
five days a week the only two days I had
the rest of Saturday and Sunday in those
days I still had to study I'm thinking
that acting is just reading lines and
you know we watching movies are we
looking at us and reading lines we don't
know there's just emotions and you have
to be natural and stuff like that so I
knew it wasn't going to be easy but I
didn't think it was going to be that
hard this is one of my favorite pieces
because it's sentimental and I mean a
lot even because freaking gave it to me
and you know 50 like my second pops like
you like my mentor you know like you and
him talk every day he just make sure I'm
always in a mind frame of trying to be
great you know trying to Excel and be
better than I was last year I wore this
piece almost every day especially like
when I'm just chilling not doing nothing
or even if I'm going somewhere I might
just throw it on if I'm I don't feel
like when I'm out there you know heavy
change so I really love this piece a lot
this was on there by Tasha diamonds in
New York City when our homies coach
shout out poops foreign
from Washington and Atlanta Georgia
because you're on my known as jury
unlimited watching my wood you know I
get a little piece of washing here and
there whenever I go today
champ shoot he got this came from
pristine it's that big boy this ring
like 20 000 right here got a little
Emerald Cuts in it this ring got Emerald
Cuts around it and you got that Big
Stone in the middle 50 right here so big
boys pristine so I hear this Antarctica
is the big boy the superstein called it
Antarctica Mr chandelier that I might
have seen fat Jordans that counted with
this one this time Big Boy you know
2 million
this one was after I upgraded and this
is called the chandelier this is called
Antarctica because it's a little bigger
so you can see the big boy right here
don't have no Waters the little one the
first one I had chandelier I had borders
between every racket this is a one out
of three this is the first Antarctica
that was made this one is 13 out of 18
to get us to pop
you with my words this is the rm1103
this is gifted to me for my gumbo family
my managers Alexis and Luca I love them
dearly they gifted his watch for me
after I had dropped the little music
gumbo pins and as you can see this is
rose gold it's the big boy from 450
right here I always love watches a
little shiny I love diamonds but once I
really got old enough to understand them
I love them even more most of the
watches that I buy
leave me in the right direction my dad
everybody tell me was watching to go get
you know that I so I don't end up with
some of this a lot of good Investments
most of all of them addicts Richard
Mills and APS and those like best
watches that all increasing value a lot
and this right here is a bad boy this is
the black AP this is all of my forget
it's my favorite watch not a lot of
these in the world I had to get this
ceramic the Finish it's not just like a
regular black shiny finish it's ceramic
easy to chip this is like top of the
line it feels like a feather and it's
like 550 almost 600 000. this is
actually Source from my uncle Rumble
Uncle Luca he got all the top of the
line Jewelers in New York so I just get
them from him whenever I want to go to
watch that hold their value and not go
for the diamonds I call my uncle and he
always leave me in the right direction
because he know everything he got over
200 watches really the best watches in
the world I feel like right now as far
as Richard Miller AP and these are
beauties just because we can't get your
hands on
you have your like legal issue with like
this accusual of like dipping off on the
watch
yeah I couldn't really talk about it
before because the case was still going
on but it was just a misunderstanding
between me and the Jeweler and it got
resolved in case you got dropped you
know I'm still growing I'm still
learning but you know it wasn't nothing
to how people were trying to make it
seem like
but you know stuff happened it got
resolved in case dropped
pristine I mean the two big boy Gumbo's
the white one and a gold one each about
150 a piece 3D at the big emeralds the
big stones in there so gumbo is a black
owned cannabis brand that my aunt and
uncle owned gun was in the Forbes and we
have a lot of different strands in the
stores around the world and their brand
has touched so many different places
that they're one of the biggest in the
world you know gumbo BMF piece coming
soon but these are carrots yeah these
big boys right here when I wear gumballs
I'll be in the carousel because the cube
are too big can't fit on these carrots
a big boy zombies you can see nobody
walking around these
she got that big boy [ __ ] 300 000.
I want some cares gotta dropped that big
care of money and you want to be that
cleaner look you're gonna have cleaner
looking you want your neck to be hurting
now this just was for the flex but this
is all trophies you know yeah I need
everybody to check out BMF on Stars you
know we about to come on every Fridays
last season every Sunday this season
will be doing every Friday you know the
biggest in the world
World Is Ours